Professor Charles
Bailyn: So,
we've been talking about
transits and I want to say a
couple things more just to round
out that discussion.
You'll recall how this works.
Transits--you get light
blocked--light from the star
blocked by the planet.
And in order for this to occur,
the orbit has to be exactly
edge-on;
otherwise, the planet doesn't
actually get in the way between
you and the star.
So, must be edge-on.
And so, what you see,
basically, although you're too
far away to see it in this kind
of detail, looks something like
this.
Here's a star,
it's got this big,
bright, shining disc,
and then crossing that star is
a darker disc from the planet.
So, it looks like you have a
little spot there.
And it's clear,
just from the geometry of this
situation, how much light is
obscured.
It's basically the ratio of the
cross-section of the planet to
that of the star.
So, the depth of the transit,
and by that I mean,
you know, the fraction of the
light that is obscured,
is equal to--that will be,
the cross-section of the planet
divided by the cross-section of
the star.
And the cross-section is just
the projected area.
And so, what that means in
practice is, here's the radius
of the star, and there's an
equivalent radius of the planet.
And it's just the ratio of the
projected areas.
Now, the area of a circle,
projected area of a sphere is a
circle.
The area of a circle,
you probably remember from
geometry, is πr^(2).
And som what this is going to
be is πr of the planet
squared, divided by πr
of the star squared and the
πs cancel.
So, it's the ratio of the
squares of the radii.
Okay, so to take an
example--supposing you were an
astronomer in some distant place
and you're looking at the--at
our own Solar System.
And you're fortunate enough to
be in a place where you can see
our Solar System edge-on.
What would you see when the
Earth transits the Sun?
So the Earth's--so here's an
example: Earth transiting the
Sun.
The radius of the Earth,
it turns out,
is something like 7 x 10^(6)
meters.
The radius of the Sun is about
100 times that,
7 x 10^(8) meters.
And so, the depth of such a
transit is the square of the
ratios of these radii.
(7 x 10^(6)) / (7 x 10^(8))^(2)
That's (10 ^(-2))^(2) = 10^(-4)
, or 0.01%.
So, that's a lot less than what
you found in section yesterday
for a Jupiter-like planet.
And the key is in this
r^(2) factor,
until the Earth is about
1/10--has about 1/10 the radius,
is about 1/10 the size of
Jupiter.
But that tenth gets squared,
so that's 100.
And so, instead of getting a 1%
dip in the light,
or approximately 1%,
you get a 1/100 of 1%.
1/100 x 1% = 10^(-4).
So, as the planet gets smaller
you--it becomes harder and
harder to see these transits.
And, if you think back on the
pictures of these light curves,
the graphs that were made,
in the observations from the
ground, you really needed to
have about a 1% dip in order to
be able to see it.
From space you can do a lot
better.
Things are much more stable,
and you might well be able to
see something like this,
but only from space and not
necessarily from the ground.
Now, having done this little
calculation, of course,
in real life,
you do it backwards.
What I did here was I assumed
that I knew what the radius is,
and I calculated what the
transit would be.
That isn't how it works with
extra solar planets because,
of course, you don't know what
the radius is.
And instead,
what happens is,
you see the transit.
And you see the transit,
and you work backwards to
figure out what the radius is.
You have to make some
assumption about what the radius
of the star is likely to be.
And so, basically,
observing a transit is a way to
get the radius of the star.
So transits give you the
radius--and this is nice,
because the radial velocity
method,
the Doppler shift
method--Doppler measurements –
also give you something about
the star.
But it's the mass not the
radius.
And then, if you have both of
these things,
then you get to put them
together and figure out what the
density is.
And that's why observing both
of these things in the same
system is so useful.
So let's do this again for the
Earth.
The mass of the Earth is 6 x
10^(24) kilograms.
The radius of the Earth we just
figured out, 7 x 10^(6) meters.
And, our hypothetical
astronomers out there in the
rest of the galaxy somewhere
would have been able to
determine this if they saw the
transit.
So now, what is the density?
Density is this Greek letter
ρ, symbolically,
and that is equal to mass over
volume, which is equal to mass
over (4/3πr) ^(3).
π = 3.
So that cancels,
which is helpful.
And let's see,
so the mass on top,
6 x 10^(24) divided by 4,
times this quantity cubed.
Now, what do we do about that?
7 x 7 = 50, right?
So, this is 7 x 50,
which is 350.
So let's see,
this is equal to (6 x 10^(24))
/ (4 x 350 x (10^(6))^(3)),
which is 10^(18),
6 x 3 = 18.
And so what's this?
Oh!
I don't know;
this is 1,400.
And so this,
then, in turn,
is equal to (6 x 10^(24)) /
(1.4 x 10^(21)) because this is
1.4 x 10^(3) x 10^(18).
6 / 1.4 = 4,
give or take,
times 10^(3).
And that's the answer,
that's the density.
In what units?
Let's see, this had better be
kilograms per meter cubed.
It's an MKS calculation.
Why?
Because that's what I started
with, kilograms and meters.
4 x 10^(3) kilograms per meter
cubed, what does that tell you?
What does that tell you?
Four times more dense than
water, excellent.
So, this is 4 times water.
Water is defined to be 10^(3)
kilograms per meter
cubed--density of water--or
rather,
a kilogram is defined so that
water has that particular
density.
It's 4 times water.
That makes it a rocky planet,
because the ices and the gases
that make up a typical gas giant
planet don't get--don't achieve
that kind of density.
And so, our hypothetical
astronomers observing this
transit would have determined
not only that the Earth is
there,
but also that it's got to be
made out of rocks.
And that is an additional piece
of information that's really
useful in trying to figure out
what's going on in these kinds
of systems.
Okay, now, it turns out that
there are some other methods for
identifying planets around other
stars.
And I want to talk about one of
them.
And the reason I haven't talked
about this one more is because
it hasn't yet discovered any
planets around other stars.
There have been lots of planets
discovered by the radial
velocity method.
There have been lots of planets
discovered now by transits,
now with the latest Hubble
Space Telescope results,
but those are not the first
methods that were tried.
For a long time,
people have been trying
something else,
and it hasn't really worked.
And this is called astrometry,
so here's another method.
Astrometry means "measuring
stars" in Greek.
And basically what this is,
is it's determining the
positions of stars to extremely
high accuracy.
Remember, the whole game here
is that the star moves,
too.
And we've been using Doppler
shift measurements to measure
the velocity of the star,
the radial velocity of the
star, as it goes round and
round.
But you could,
in principle,
also try and figure out that
the actual position of the star
in space moves a little bit too.
So, observing change in
position of the star--now that
change is quite small.
And you'll recall that we
started out a few weeks ago
saying, you know,
you don't see the star all that
accurately because of
atmospheric distortion and
optical problems in your
telescope.
You just see this big blob of
light.
And the key point here is that
it is actually not--if you have
enough light,
you can determine the center of
a big blob of light really quite
accurately.
Determine the center of a blob
of light to much greater
accuracy than the extent of the
blob.
So, you know,
I take a picture of a star and
I see something that kind of
looks like this.
And that's big and ugly and
hard to deal with,
except, you know,
the accuracy of the position of
that blob isn't limited by the
extent.
You know that the center is
somewhere around here.
And if that blob were to move
slightly so that the center took
a little--went around in circles
like this,
you'd actually be able to see
that as this big blob sort of
moves slowly around.
And that's the trick with
astrometry.
So, you do these repeated
measurements of the precise
position of the star,
and you ought to be able to see
it going around in circles.
So, we have,
in fact, all the equations we
need to deal with this already.
And so, let's just go straight
to a particular exercise,
a calculation.
How big a change in the Sun's
position due to the planet
Jupiter, because that's the most
massive and will make the most
difference,
would you see if you're on
Alpha Centauri?--would an Alpha
Centauri astronomer observe?
So here's the situation:
you're sitting on Alpha
Centauri.
You're looking back--which is
the nearest star,
you may recall.
You're looking back at the
Solar System,
and you're hoping to see the
change in movement of the Sun
due to the presence of the
planet Jupiter.
So, the first thing to say
about this is,
what do we mean by change in
position?
Change in position.
What we're talking about is an
angle.
We talked about this in a
different context before.
Here's the observer.
Here's the star.
And the star's moving,
it's going to move up to here.
And what we want is to draw
this triangle,
and we want an angle.
And then D_2
over here is the amount by which
the star moves,
D_1 over here
is the distance to the star.
And we want the angular change
in position, because that's what
we mean when we make a position
measurement in space.
Okay, so that's the first thing
is to understand what the answer
ought to look like.
It's got to be some kind of
angle.
And then the second thing is,
I've done my usual trick here
of not giving you a whole bunch
of information that you're going
to need.
And so, the first thing you
have to do in order to line
up--try and set up the answer is
you have to figure out some
actual answer.
So, the mass of the Sun is
obviously equal to the mass of
the Sun;
that's easy.
The mass of Jupiter is equal to
2 x 10^(27) kilograms,
that's 1/1000 of the mass of
the Sun.
The distance from Alpha Cen to
us--Sun--from Alpha Cen to the
Sun is about 1 parsec.
I think I mentioned that
before, because this is the
closest star that there is.
And the semi-major axis of
Jupiter's orbit is equal to 5
Astronomical Units.
I wrote that down on the first
day of class.
So you're going to need all
this information.
Now, here's the trick;
here's Jupiter doing its 5
Astronomical Unit thing,
and then the Sun in the middle.
Here's the center of mass,
center of mass.
And the Sun is doing a little
circuit in the other direction,
always making sure that it's on
the other side of the center of
mass from the planet.
That's what a center of mass
means, right?
And then we can take--at one
point here's the--let's say,
here's the Sun and here's
Jupiter.
And we take this little line
here, and the whole of the
distance here is
a_total.
And the distance from the
planet to the center of mass is
a_planet,
and this tiny little distance
here is a_star.
And what we need to look for is
a_star in this
case, because we're watching the
star go round in circles,
not the planet.
And then, the usual equations
apply where M_star
a_star is
equal to
M_planet
a_planet.
We've seen this equation in
dealing with velocities,
but it's the same thing in
distances,
because, the time that it takes
to go around these circles is
one orbital period--is the same
in both cases.
So, if the velocity is slower,
then you cover less ground.
Or, to put it a different way,
if you're going in a smaller
circle, you're not moving as
fast.
So, it's the same equation.
And so, let's do this.
a_star =
(M_planet /
M_star) x
a_planet.
That's 5 A.U.
in the case of--in this
particular case.
And I've already said that the
mass of the planet is equal to
10^(-3) times the mass of the
star here.
So, this is 10^(-3).
So, this is 5 x 10^(-3)
Astronomical Units.
That's how far the--that's the
radius of the Sun's orbit around
the center of mass with Jupiter,
if you want to think of it that
way.
But that's not the answer we
want.
We want an angle.
And this in A.U.,
and this, here,
in parsecs, will give us angle
in arc seconds.
And this is a particularly easy
one.
We already have 5 x 10^(-3)
A.U., and the distance is 1
parsec.
And so, this is 5 x 10^(-3) arc
seconds.
Five milli-arc seconds.
Now, that's much smaller than
the size of the blob of light
from Alpha Centauri.
But, as I said,
you can see the motion of the
center of a blob of light to
fairly high accuracy,
and this is pretty readily
observable.
So, folks sitting on Alpha
Centauri would know that
the--who have our kind--our
level of technology would
already know that Jupiter exists
from this method.
Interestingly,
we can look at Alpha Centauri,
right?
You can do this backwards and
you get exactly the same answer,
because Alpha Centauri is a
Sun-like star,
has exactly the same mass,
and we don't observe any such
motion in Alpha Cen.
And so, there is no
Jupiter-like planet around Alpha
Cen.
We know that because if there
had been, we would have seen it
through this--through this
method.
Now, you can do the same thing,
let me do it quickly,
for the Earth.
Supposing you want to detect
the Earth in this way.
So
a_planet--so
this is for Earth.
a of the planet is now 1
A.U.
instead of 5 A.U.s.
Mass of the planet is 6 x
10^(24).
So mass of the planet over mass
of the star is (6 x 10^(24)) /
(2 x 10^(30)).
That's 3 x 10^(-6).
And so the a of the Sun
due to the Earth now,
not due to Jupiter,
is equal to 1 A.U.
That's the size of the planet
times the ratio of the masses,
which is 3 x 10^(-6).
So it's 3 x 10^(-6) A.U.,
much less than for Jupiter,
which was 5 x 10^(-3).
And then, Alpha equals
D_2 /
D_1.
(3 x 10^(-6)) / 1.
Three micro-arc seconds.
This is not observable,
at least not with current
technology.
So, our friends on Alpha
Centauri, who know that there's
Jupiter, don't yet know that
Earth exists,
because this is so much smaller
than the effect due to Jupiter.
And it's smaller for two
different reasons.
One reason is that the mass of
Earth is small,
so this ratio is small.
The other is that the Earth's
orbit is shorter,
so it's 1 A.U.
instead of 5 A.U.
So, you're multiplying two
numbers together.
Instead of multiplying 5 by
10^(-3), you're multiplying 1 by
10^(-6).
And so, both of those numbers
are smaller.
And so, the effect is that much
smaller.
So we can't yet--our friends on
Alpha Centauri can't tell
whether we have Earths,
and likewise we can't tell
whether Alpha Centauri has an
Earth.
So, one of the interesting
things about the astrometry
method, and this is why I bring
the whole thing up,
is that it favors big orbits.
The bigger the orbit,
the bigger the motion of both
the star and the planet.
This is exactly opposite to
what happens with the radial
velocity method.
Radial velocity method favors
small orbits,
because in small orbits,
things go faster,
and you're looking at the
velocity.
So, this favors big orbits,
and that's the opposite of
radial velocity measurements.
And it also favors massive
planets: the more massive the
planet, the better off you'll
be, which is the same as the
radial velocity method.
And so, this is useful,
one of the--if you're trying to
figure out what kinds of things
are out there,
it's helpful to be looking with
several different methods,
which select for different
kinds of objects that you can
look for.
And so, you can call these
selection effects.
And, you know,
if you're looking at radial
velocities, you're going to miss
all the large orbit stars.
And so, it would be nice to
also look with astrometry,
so that you can see other kinds
of stars--other kinds of
planets.
Now, let's see.
The astrometry method has one
other feature that it
needs--star needs to be nearby.
This is a--this is a question
that doesn't arise in radial
velocity, and it's because of
this term.
It's because of this term here.
You're looking for alpha.
So, even once you figure it
out, how much the star moves,
you've got to divide by the
distance of the star.
So, for example,
if you're looking at something
10 parsecs away instead of 1
parsec away then you've got only
1/10 the effect.
And so, while people sitting on
Alpha Centauri can see the
effect of Jupiter,
people ten times further away,
on some other star,
which is still quite close in
galactic terms,
would not be able to see that
exact same effect even though,
of course, the Sun's moving the
same way regardless of who's
looking at it.
The further away you get,
the smaller the effect becomes.
That's why nobody's--largely,
I think, that's why nobody has
successfully used the astrometry
effect,
because it only works out well
on very nearby stars,
and there's just a limited
number of those to look at.
And so, let me summarize all
these different methods now--oh
good.
By just making a little table
of the so-called selection
effects.
These are what kinds of things
are easy to see and what kinds
of things are not so easy to see
for a given method.
And we've got three different
methods, so let's make a little
table here.
Method;
what kind of orbits get picked
out;
what kind of planets get picked
for a given orbit;
and other considerations.
And here we go.
So, the first one we talked
about was radial velocities.
This is the Doppler shift,
and this picks out short or
small orbits.
Short if you're thinking about
the period, small if you're
thinking about the semi-major
axis,
because the smaller the orbit,
the faster the planet has to
go, and therefore,
the faster the star has to
respond.
It picks out massive planets,
because the more massive the
planet, the greater the reflex
motion of the star.
And you'll recall that it does
make a difference how the thing
is oriented.
If it's less than edge-on you
see only part of the motion,
so it helps a little to be
close to edge-on.
Now, for the next method,
which are transits,
where the star gets in the way,
this criteria that you have to
be edge-on is much,
much more important.
Because, in the case of the
radial velocity,
you know, if you're not
edge-on, it sort of gradually
becomes a smaller,
and smaller,
and smaller effect.
But gradually,
there's no big moment where you
can't see it at all.
But with transits,
if you're not edge-on,
you don't see anything.
It's not that the effect gets
smaller, it's that the effect
disappears altogether if you're
not sufficiently edge-on so that
the planet gets away--gets in
the way of your line of sight to
the star.
This also favors short or small
orbits.
But--and that's because it has
to be edge-on.
How close to edge-on you have
to be depends on how far the
star is from the planet.
Here's what I mean.
Here's the star and here's
the--here's you.
And, supposing there's a planet
here, then that will just get in
the way.
But if there's a planet here a
little further away on that
same--in the same kind of orbit,
only more distant,
then it doesn't get in the way.
And so more distant--let me
phrase that differently.
Larger semi-major axis makes it
harder to have a transit.
You have to--closer to edge-on.
If you were out here,
you'd have to--see here,
anything within this little
angle here will cause a transit.
But if you're out here,
let's see, it would have to be
anything within this smaller
angle.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, it's just,
the further away you hold your
thumb from your eye,
the less you have to move your
arm to cover a given thing.
All right.
And also, in this case,
for transits,
let's see, the planet has to be
large, physically,
in terms of its size.
And so, it's not so much the
mass, but the size of the thing
that matters.
So, if you have a big,
but light, planet,
a big fluffy thing,
that'll work well for transits,
but not so well for radial
velocities.
Then, finally,
this astrometry method I just
described favors large orbits in
contrast to the other effects.
It is irrelevant whether it's
edge-on, because if it's
face-on, then the star goes
around in a circle,
like this, and,
you can see it.
If it's edge-on,
the star goes around in a
circle like this,
and you see it moving back and
forth as if it was in a line,
so you can do it either way.
So, that's irrelevant,
but has to be nearby--must be
nearby.
And, like the radial velocity
method, you favor massive
planets.
So, these are three of the
methods that are commonly being
used now.
Yes, question?
Student: So,
does the orbit have to be
larger between methods so that
the center of mass is
sufficiently far away?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yes.
So the--yes,
that's exactly right.
The orbit has to be large so
that the center of mass has to
be sufficiently far away from
the star,
so that it travels a big enough
distance to be able to see.
That's exactly right.
There's one more method that's
commonly in use called
"microlensing," which is really
cool,
but I'm not going to talk about
it, because it's a relativistic
method and so we haven't talked
about relativity yet.
We'll cycle back and talk about
this later on in the course.
And this has actually worked,
and I will restrain myself from
trying to explain it in the
remaining fifteen minutes of
this particular segment of the
course.
We'll come back to it.
But this sort of set of
selection effects is a good
thing to know,
because then,
if you do all of these things
and you compare them to each
other, and each method has a
different selection effect,
then you have a fighting chance
of figuring out what's actually
out there rather than what you
are simply able to see because
of the particular method you're
using.
S,o it's a good idea to be
trying to do all of these things
at once.
Okay, let me end this segment
by talking about some space
missions--yes,
question yes?
Student: So essentially
there's--if there's a similar
tech--people of technology
somewhere out there,
they can't see this?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: We can--yes,
so there--if there's people
elsewhere with our technology,
they can't detect the Earth.
That is the same as saying we
can't detect Earths around other
stars.
That is the case right now.
However, technology marches on,
and, as I'll show you,
in ten, fifteen years,
that may no longer be true.
So, if the aliens out there are
even fifteen years further
advanced than we are in
technology, they might know that
we're here.
Other questions, yes?
Student: Even supposing
that we could detect the Earth
around another star,
would the presence of a more
massive planet sort of mess that
up so that we can't?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Would the presence
of a more massive planet disrupt
our potential detections of an
Earth-like planet?
Not necessarily.
Remember, I showed you
that--the radial velocity curves
where they had detected several
planets in the same system?
What you do is you take the
effect of the massive planet,
you figure out what the mass
and orientation of the massive
planet is,
and you remove that from your
data and then you look for the
little wiggles left over.
And you could do that
effectively with any of these
methods.
The example I showed was the
radial velocity thing,
where there were superposed
sine curves,
but you could also do it--there
could be three different
transits, and so you'd get a big
lump for the big star,
and then a little lump for the
little star.
And if the little star's
closer, you'd get them more
often.
And, similarly,
in astrometry,
you could get it moving back
and forth due to a massive
planet,
and then a motion on top of
that due to some other planet.
So it--for--in all of these
cases the effect of one massive
planet could be taken out so
that you could see the result.
Now, what's perhaps more
important is,
the presence of the massive
planet could screw up the orbit
of the Earth-like planet.
This whole migration idea--this
Jupiter comes cruising into the
Inner Solar System,
and then us earthlings are in
trouble because our orbit gets
disrupted and we fall into the
Sun,
or something like that.
So, the bigger problem is not
detecting it,
but whether it permits the
planet to be there at all.
Other questions?
Yes?
Student: Will we get our
problem sets back?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Will you get your
problem set back?
Yes, that's an easy question,
end of the class.
Other questions?
Yeah.
Student: Will you be
posting the slides before the
test?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: We'll post these
slides before the test,
yes, yeah.
Other things, yes?
Student: Why is it that
when you calculate a it's
not actually--this was the
method you were just doing,
the astrometry method--why is
it not 2a because it's
going from one side of the
center of mass to the other?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Oh,
the--a is defined as the
semi-major axis.
It's just a definition thing.
Student: But isn't the
star going [inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yes,
so the star travels a circle
with radius a,
so you're right.
It goes from one side to the
other, so the distance the star
goes is actually 2a. And
so that's just a definition
question of-- Student:
But is it--can't you observe the
star at one point or another?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yes,
you're right.
So that the total angular
change is--you're right,
is actually 2a.
And what I was calculating
there is the radius of the
little circle that it goes
around.
But you're absolutely right
the--in fact the distance--it's
like for the radial velocity
method,
the actual change in radial
velocity is from the peak to the
trough, but the number we quote
is the amplitude of the sine
curve,
so you're right about that.
Other questions?
Okay, let me show you some
things in--work in progress,
and in particular space
missions that are being planned
to explore this further.
So, the first of these is the
so-called Kepler Mission,
which is going to look for
transits.
I showed you the Hubble Space
Telescope, transit curve,
which is much,
much better than anything you
can do from the ground.
So, obviously the place to look
for transits is in space.
From space you could see
transits the size of Earths--of
planets the size of Earth,
whereas from the ground,
you wouldn't be able to see
that.
And also--and so what they want
to do is send up a mission
that's going to do nothing but
make high precision measurements
of stars in order to look for
transits.
So, the problem with the space
telescope is everybody wants to
use it for all kinds of things.
There's relatively
little--limited amounts of time
for any one particular project.
It's also not perfectly
designed for making these kinds
of transits observations,
so this is going to be a
mission which is set up for the
express purpose of making very
high precision measurements of
the brightness of stars over,
and over, and over again.
And the problem with this is
just the general problem with
transits: that you only see the
ones that are edge-on.
So, you've got to look at lots
and lots of stars.
Even if lots of them have
planets, you'll only see a few
transits.
But this is designed to carry
out that mission,
so they're going to be lots of
transits observed,
including transits from
Earth-like--from Earth-sized
stars.
So, this will be the first
moment when this thing gets
launched that we'll really have
a good handle on being able to
detect an Earth-sized planet.
So, if the aliens have launched
their equivalent of Kepler,
they're looking at us right
now,
provided our Solar System
happens to be exactly edge-on
from their perspective.
This is due to launch in a year
or two.
It's under construction.
It's ready to roll,
and this thing will be up in
space taking data by the
time--within the next couple of
years.
So, that's an exciting thing to
look forward to.
A little bit further into the
future is something called SIM,
this is the Space
Interferometry Mission,
and this does astrometry.
And it's going to improve the
accuracy of positions of stars
from what we now have,
which is in the milli-arc
second range,
1/1000 of an arc second,
to the micro-arc second range,
1/1,000,000 of an arc second.
And again, as we just did in
that little calculation,
that will, in principle,
enable us to look for
Earth-like systems.
Now, the limitation on this is
that--is this business that for
astrometry, you have to look at
nearby stars,
and the nearer the star,
the better.
And if you get far out into
these--into the galaxy,
then the method becomes less
sensitive.
It's also true that,
you know, this method favors
long orbits, and space missions
tend not to last for forty
years.
And so, if you're looking for
Neptune, which has,
you know, a many-decade-long
orbit,
it's not clear that this is
going to be around for long
enough to actually make those
measurements.
So, this astrometry thing is
kind of squeezed between the
requirement of the method to
have long orbits and the
requirement of human beings to
get results in a relatively
short amount of time.
Nevertheless,
this will be a factor of a
thousand improvement over what
we can do from the ground.
This mission is authorized.
It's kind of under
construction,
but it's one of those things
where it's going to launch in
five to seven years.
That was also true five to
seven years ago.
And it will probably--on our
pessimistic days we think it
will still be true five to seven
years from now.
It's always five years in the
future, both for technical
reasons, and for funding and
political reasons.
But there's some feeling that
one of these days they'll
actually get around to doing it.
But it's certainly further in
the future than the Kepler
Mission is.
And then, the great granddaddy
of all planet missions is
something called the Terrestrial
Planet Finder,
the TPF.
This is a huge NASA commitment,
and they want to directly image
the planet.
So, this is fundamentally
different from everything else.
This is--we're going to
actually take a picture of the
light from the planet.
We're going to give up this
silly business of observing the
star to infer the presence of
the planet.
We're actually going to look at
the planet itself.
In order to do that,
you have to get rid of the
light from the star.
You have to blank out the light
of the star, because otherwise,
as we saw, it'll drown out the
planet.
And there are a couple of
different ways you can do it.
One is basically just masking.
You just put a big opaque thing
somewhere in the optical path of
the telescope,
and it just blocks out the
light of the star,
but it's carefully sized so
that the light of stuff around
it can still get in.
There are also more
sophisticated optical
methods--something called
interferometry,
which I won't explain right
now, which can have the same
effect of nulling out the light
from the star.
And so, we then observe the
planetary light directly.
The best way to do this is not
in optical light but in
infrared.
Optical light is where stars
give out most of their light.
Planets give out most of their
light in the infrared.
You may be aware,
we all glow in the dark,
but we glow in the dark in the
infrared,
that's why the military uses
those interesting infrared
goggles, which turn everything
green.
What those do is they take
infrared photons and they ingest
infrared photons.
And they emit green light so
that you can see infrared,
and that's how they do these
night vision goggles.
And that's because at the
temperatures on ordinary
planets, we glow in the
infrared,
which is why you don't see each
other glowing in the dark,
because your eyes don't detect
infrared.
But if you're going to be
looking for planets,
you're much better off looking
in the infrared than in ordinary
light.
And then, once you can see the
light from a planet,
you get to do a really cool
thing,
which is, you get to examine
the spectrum of that planet to
find out what the atmosphere is
made of.
And we talked a little bit
about spectral features,
which come from different atoms
or molecules.
And once you actually see the
light from the planet as opposed
to the light from the star,
you can actually study in
detail what that star's--what
that planet's atmosphere is made
of.
This, by the way,
is how one goes about detecting
life on planet Earth.
There was a very cute
experiment a little while ago.
They were sending a mission to
Jupiter, the Galileo Mission,
which is now at Jupiter doing
science.
But the way they did it was
funny.
They sent it not outward toward
Jupiter, but inward toward
Venus.
It took a swing around Venus.
It turns out,
if you do it right,
and you swing around a planet,
you can pick up extra speed.
And so, to get this thing out
to Jupiter, they had it swing
around Venus,
then come back to Earth and
swing around Earth.
And each time it did one of
these swings,
it picked up speed,
so it got to Jupiter actually
faster that way--a very clever
bit of orbital dynamics.
But the consequence of it was
that this mission,
one of our prime missions to
look at other planets with all
the various instruments that we
like to look at other planets
with,
swung by near to Earth.
And so, somebody had the very
clever idea, let's use our
standard suite of exploration
instruments and see if we can
detect the existence of life on
Earth using one of the
satellites that we used to
explore the rest of the Solar
System.
And people had all kinds of
thoughts about what would be
detectable--you know,
cities at night,
you know, you would be able to
see lights on the dark side,
the Great Wall of China,
you would be able to
detect--no.
Turns out that the strongest
sign of life on Earth is the
fact that the atmosphere
contains methane.
Now, the atmosphere,
of course, has a lot of oxygen.
Methane, you may recall,
is CH4, and if you put a little
bit of methane into an oxygen
atmosphere it immediately
dissociates and you get water
and carbon dioxide because of
all the free oxygen.
So there shouldn't be any
methane in the atmosphere,
but there is,
and you can detect it by
looking at the infrared spectrum
of the atmosphere.
Now, what does it mean that
there's methane in our
atmosphere?
It means there's a continuous
source of methane pumping into
the atmosphere all the time.
What is the source of that
methane?
It is, as Carl Sagan,
delicately put it,
bovine flatulence.
Cow farts.
And just digestion,
in general, has an output of
methane, which is continually
piping into the atmosphere.
And if that weren't happening,
that happens from biological
activity, and if that weren't
happening,
there wouldn't be any methane
observable in the atmosphere.
So, what you do is,
if you find some other planet,
if you look at the atmospheric
chemistry,
and you see if there's
something in there that's out of
equilibrium that could only be
continually replenished by
biological activity.
And having both oxygen and
methane at the same time is one
such indicator.
So, the hope would be that we
could not only see the light
from the planet,
but we'd be able to detect the
presence of biological activity
as well.
So how do you go about doing
this?
Bovine flatulence equals
life--words to live by.
Let's see, so here's how you do
it.
You need to have very high
resolution;
you need to be able to separate
the light from the star,
from the light from the planet,
to the greatest extent
possible.
Turns out, the way you do this
is you have space telescopes
spaced pretty widely apart.
That gives you the best handle
on the resolution.
But they have to know where
each other is to a precision
very substantially greater than
the wavelength of the light that
they're observing.
And so, they need to be able to
tell the distance apart of these
things to tiny fractions of a
meter--"picometer metrology" is
the technical word.
A picometer is 10^(-12) meters
and metrology is just measuring
how far apart you are.
So, they need to be able to
figure out--to formation fly,
and know how far apart they are
to about the width of an atom or
so.
You want to image in the
infrared.
Mid-infrared imaging wants you
to--pushes you beyond Jupiter.
The problem is that inside the
orbit of Jupiter,
there's all this warm dust in
our Solar System.
And so, it's like the sky is
bright all the time from all the
infrared emission,
from the dust.
So, you've got to go out into
the colder parts of the Solar
System to do this.
So we're--what we're going to
do, the plan is,
you're going to build a half
dozen or so things,
each of which is about ten
times the size of the space
telescope.
We're going to move them out
beyond Jupiter and formation fly
them in this--to this extremely
high precision.
This is not something we're
capable of doing right now.
But there is a twenty-five
year-old;
twenty-five year so-called
roadmap, a series of missions
along the way,
which is going to
simultaneously be good missions
in their own right,
and develop the technology.
SIM is one of these missions.
It's going to develop the high
precision spatial imaging that
you need for this.
JWST is the acronym for the
next-generation space telescope,
which is due to be launched in
2012.
That's basically one such
telescope, but orbiting the
Earth.
That's a milestone.
And there are various other
milestones along this roadmap.
And the hope is that in
twenty-five years,
with, you know,
25 to 50 billion dollars,
we could actually do this
thing.
And so, here's the little
artist's conception of these
guys flying in formation outside
of the orbit of Jupiter.
Then, I guess this represents
the Sun down in the middle of
the Solar System.
They're looking out this way,
finding life on other planets.
And the big problem with this
whole mission is that it's been
cancelled, because a decision
has been made that it's--this is
a very big,
expensive mission,
and the decision has been made
that if you're going to do
something big and expensive,
you ought to go to Mars,
instead.
Put people on Mars, instead.
However, this is a twenty-five
year time scale.
Things get cancelled and
un-cancelled every three or four
years, so, who knows exactly
what's going to happen.
And I think this may reappear
in the NASA plan at some point
in the future.
And that's sort of the ultimate
that people can think of now in
terms of find--studying planets
around other stars.
Okay, that's what I got to say
about this, and a test on
Thursday.